-Fire crackle soothingly-
-Fire crackle, men screaming, and yelling less soothingly-
In July 1588
beacons were lit across England
to warn of the arrival of the Spanish armada.
Elizabeth's darkest fears had come true.
England was at war.
Open war at last.
It was something that Elizabeth had twisted and turned
for twenty years to avoid.
Elizabeth hated war
because it was so expensive.
It was also unbelievable risky.
The loss of Calais had destroyed her sister Mary's reputation.
And Elizabeth well knew that a similar
unforeseen disaster could undo all her own work.
Elizabeth loathed war because as a woman
she couldn't lead her own armies. Instead,
she had to give their command to hot-willed men
who would disobey her orders and might even turn
her own forces against her.
-Fire gush sound-
Title: Heart of a King
The slide into war begun nearly twenty years before.
-horn music-
By the early 1570s Elizabeth
had triumphed over her opponents in England.
She had seen off a rebellion and executed the ring leaders.
Including her own own cousin, the Duke of Norfolk.
There was a fragile peace in England.
But Elizabeth was in constant danger.
She had powerful enemies abroad headed by the Pope.
who like a sixteenth century Ayatollah
had signed a fatwa
on the Protestant English Queen.
"Who soever senders her out of the world
with the pious intention of doing God's service
not only does not sin,
but gains merit."
Elizabeth had powerful
Catholic enemies at home as well.
Mary Queen of Scots had been Elizabeth's
prisoner since her desperate flight from Scotland
in 1568.
Mary had a strong claim to the English throne
through her great grandfather
Henry the seventh.
On her arrive to England Mary
identified herself passionately with Catholicism.
-foot steps and anticipation music-
Mary's faith set her on
a collision course with Elizabeth. Especially,
as relations between Catholics and Protestants in Europe
were about to explode.
-anticipation music intensifies-
In Paris, on Saint Bartholomew day the twenty-fourth
of August 15, 1572
Catholics began a massacre of
their Protestant neighbors.
-holy sounding music sung by male singers-
Everywhere there were people who fled
and others ran after them crying, "kill! Kill!"
There was no mercy either for age or for sex.
It was in very truth a massacre.
The streets were strewn with naked
mutilated corpses. The river was covered with them.
Sir Francis Walsingham, Elizabeth's
ambassador in Paris, barely escaped with his life.
The Queen recalled him to London
and gave him a new job
masterminding England's security.
Walsingham quickly identified
public enemy number one.
Nothing is more necessary then that the realm might
be delivered off her.
If the saw be not sound
I feel we shall have a Bartholomew breakfast.
Mary was a figurehead for Catholics everywhere
who wanted to depose Elizabeth.
And Mary knew there could be only one way out
of her confinement.
I will not leave my prison, save as Queen of England.
The St. Bartholomew's massacre heightened the fear
of a bloody Catholic rising in England.
It also plunged France into a civil war.
Elizabeth relied on France as a counter-balance
to the mighty Spanish Empire, which controlled much of
Europe including the Netherlands.
That is modern day Holland, Belgium,
and north eastern France.
But although England might fear the
Catholic neighbors
she couldn't live without them.
Because in the Netherlands was England's biggest export
market. The booming city of Antilles.
In 1532 the year before Elizabeth's
birth this magnificent new exchange
was built.
Antilles was now a combination of the city
and Wallstreet and the most important
commodity traded was English wool.
The English traders held center stage
doing their deals here
in the middle of the trading floor.
As usual money talks
and the volume of the London/Antilles trade meant that the
Netherlands were usually England's
chief over seas ally.
The rulers of the Netherlands in the sixteenth century
were the Habsburg.
One of them was Philip of Spain
who had been married to, Mary Tudor, Elizabeth's sister.
When Mary died Philip tried to keep hold of England by
proposing to Elizabeth.
But the new Queen refused him.
Neither Elizabeth
nor her people
wanted to be ruled by
a foreigner again.
The people of the Netherlands didn't much like
Spanish rule either and in 1576
united behind Prince William of Orange.
He was horrified by the brutality of Spanish rule
and he turned to Elizabeth as a fellow Protestant
for help.
Elizabeth now proved herself to be a
Queen of deception.
Instead of intervening directly
as her father Henry the eighth might have done
Elizabeth preferred to get others to do
her dirty work for her.
Elizabeth's policy towards the Netherlands trotted a tight rope.
She didn't wish to be seen giving open help to
Philips rebellious subjects
because that would break the rules of the royal club
to which both she and Philip belonged.
Nor on the other hand did she
want to see Philip
be established a real Empire of the Netherlands.
That would enable Philip to
resume the persecution of the Protestants.
Still worse, it would enable
him to turn the Netherlands into a spring board
for the invasion of England.
SO...
every time Philip looked as though he was getting the upper hand
Elizabeth threw large amounts of gold at the Dutch rebels
to stiffen their resistance.
But mighty Spain would not be beaten by a
Dutch revolt. And William's rebellion began to buckle
under the force of Spanish arms.
*Gun shots and explosions*
Elizabeth needed someone else to try and stop Philip.
*Gun shots, yelling,  and explosions*
Enter the Duke of... his mother
had put him forward as a husband to Elizabeth.
When he was just eighteen she was thirty-nine.
But he was putridly puny and
and scarred by Smallpox. Elizabeth
hadn't been interested.
But six years later he began to intrigue her.
The Duke belonged to the French royal family.
But as the youngest son he had little chance of
inheriting the throne.
So he had to look elsewhere for a kingdom of his own.
he hoped to find one in the Netherlands
If Elizabeth could pull the right strings
he would be the perfect pullet
to oppose Philip.
Elizabeth flourished a diplomatic trump card.
Now a bit worn and passed its best
but still playable
Marriage was
on the table again.
*non English language*
His ambition needed money.
He began secret correspondence with Elizabeth
but his letters didn't talk of interest rates.
Instead, they used the language of love.
*non English language*
She was his "belle majestea" (beautiful majesty).
He was her slave.
His declarations combined devotion and passion
with just a tasteful hint of
eroticism/